a very good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast our top story this morning we
start with a warning to teachers from
the government that they will need to
merge classes and reintroduce hybrid
learning in order to deal with staff
shortages caused by the spread of
omicron
schools around the uk returned this week
from the christmas holidays as ministers
predict mass staff shortages this month
news two this morning of a critical
situation at hospitals in lincolnshire
more on that in a moment first let's
bring you up to date with the key
developments on schools the government
has already said that secondary school
students in england will need to wear
masks in lessons from tomorrow and
promise to provide 7 000 air purifiers
to schools to help classroom ventilation
but there's concern it may be february
before some schools get them
the education secretary is now urging
schools to prepare for the merging of
classes into larger groups and to be
ready to introduce a hybrid of
face-to-face and remote learning if
there aren't enough teachers is
encouraging the use of temporary and
supply staff to cover classes
the government is also advising that all
secondary school students should
undertake one on-site test when they
return to school and all students should
take two lateral flow tests at home each
week after that
it comes as the labour party said that
half a million eligible 16 and 17 year
olds across the uk remain unvaccinated
more than four months after the
government said they'd be offered a jab
oksana prizak an epidemiologist at ucl
told us the proposed measures are a good
start but a greater focus on ventilation
is needed to prevent the spread of
omicron in schools no one is saying that
masks alone will be the only solution uh
in the uk we've also introduced 7 000
new filtration devices which is a good
start
but we've been calling for uh better
filtration for gosh over two years now
so more can be done to ensure that every
school has uh appropriate hepa filters
in installed that can remove these
aerosols um very effectively the this
the evidence is now there
to show that this is one of the most
effective ways
well i'm joined now by the education
secretary nadim zahawi a very good
morning to you thank you very much
indeed for joining us can i first begin
by asking you at the data on omicron how
many patients are in hospital at the
moment with the omicron variant
uh good morning uh sally um so the the
data is obviously published
daily
and
the hospital
numbers of people in hospital
with
coronavirus has begun to rise um in
the over 50s which we are concerned
about
but on the whole
actually the number of people in icu has
come down which is good news but we keep
a very close eye on those
numbers and
those patients
in hospital
at the moment
is very important
do you know how many of those patients
with omicron are on ventilators at the
moment
i don't have the data uh with beyond the
uh those in on ventilators um but uh on
the whole we are not seeing the same
pattern as with delta where
um we had a much greater number of
people
um on uh ventilation and there seems to
be a shorter period of time of people uh
in icu as well uh and those who are
being admitted um with covid rather than
for covid is also about a third of that
number
now
uh the minister stephen barkley
yesterday uh said that the data doesn't
support the need for any new
restrictions of course plan b is being
revised on wednesday when uh ministers
return when parliament returns
is it fair to say that we can expect
nothing to change that no restrictions
will be lifted but nothing will be added
either
well the review is on wednesday
and at the moment there's nothing in the
data
that would uh suggest uh to me to us
that we need to uh go further but we
have to be uh careful with that because
obviously
if we see more leakage of infection in
the over 50s
because most of the sort of the surge
in infections from omicron has been in
the under 50s
then there is more likely that those
people end up with severe infection and
hospitalization but the good news is
obviously that 90 percent of those
people over 50 have had the booster jab
that is the real protection against
severe infection and hospitalization so
at the moment there's nothing in the
data to suggest that we need to go
further but of course we will look at
wednesday's review and then beyond that
keep monitoring the data very carefully
now of course many schools return
tomorrow secondary school pupils have
been informed they need to now wear face
masks and that every child returning to
the classroom needs to take a test
before they do now there's not been much
warning this was announced yesterday
most children go back to school tomorrow
48 hours notice including a bank holiday
will schools be ready with all these
tests
uh sally actually on tests and i want to
thank school leaders and teachers for
everything they did last
year where we had 99.9 of schools open i
deliberately before christmas made sure
that we had an alternative supply for
schools
for the testing that we will be
conducting
this coming week in secondary schools
and that has really gone down well with
the
head teachers with teachers that we've
got that supply in place we also
anticipated the staff shortages and i
had a call
to retire teachers those who can come
back to the profession a number of my
colleagues jonathan gullis caroline
ansel sir michael wilshaw
a number in my department have come
forward
to
uh join that effort uh that that uh i
referred to as a sort of the that blitz
spirit of joining in to make sure that
the first week of term and then uh
subsequent weeks are really uh positive
and we get as many children back in
school back in education as possible
because all the evidence you look at
what rachel d'souza the children's
commissioner's survey the big ask
suggests that children are much
better off being in school for their
health their well-being and of course
for their education
which is why it's my prior priority to
make sure that those tests are conducted
and we have plenty of uh support for
that and supply and of course
the staff challenges and ventilation
because we distributed 350 000 co2
monitors last year and looking at those
uh i wanted to make sure that we had
initially a thousand uh
air purifiers that we bought last year
for special schools which are the most
vulnerable and for alternative provision
schools i've just added another seven
thousand um air purifiers for those
schools who can't
mitigate if the co2 monitors are
suggesting that they need to open
windows or have better ventilation
those 7 000 air purifiers will help
with that as well so this is a you know
a big effort on behalf of everybody uh
on the front line i want to thank them
and the support staff of course for
everything they'll do this week so we
can get you know a school reopening
being incredibly uh positive and uh it's
absolutely the right thing to do so uh i
think we we the mitigations we've put in
place are the right ones on on masks you
know i don't want mr hallway if i may
just jump in there on that issue of
ventilators the 7 000 extra that have
been announced sky news has learned that
many of those won't actually be in
schools until february is that
acceptable
so we had a thousand before christmas
for them the schools that uh are special
and ap that will most uh need them by
the way the the thing to remember uh the
350 000 co2 monitors that we distributed
to schools allow them to monitor
the
atmosphere in the classroom and the
additional 7 000 are really there to
help if those schools
need that additional purifier on the
whole the response we've had back from
the data from the 350 000 uh co2
monitors has been incredibly positive
that most schools can actually deal with
this uh through other measures like you
know opening windows and of course
better ventilation
good to know let's just rattle through a
few more questions because there's quite
a few things i'd like to get through if
i may just on the issue of testing you
want pupils to take two lateral flow
tests each week
after their initial test when they
return to school what happens if parents
can't access lateral flow tests next
week what do they do
so one of the things that we've done is
increased the supply of lateral flow
tests so it was about 100 million a
month it's now 300 million a month
and the deliveries so we've trebled the
deliveries from about 300 000 a day to
900 000
a day
so the supply
will absolutely be there if people
feel that um you know
they can't get the supply they should
just refresh their
web page and it is pretty much um
delivering uh with that additional
supply coming through for school testing
i deliberately
chose to make sure that we had a
different route of supply for the
schools which i'm confident all schools
have
now for this week for their testing that
they need to carry out for the secondary
school pupils to be
tested and feel safe in class
next thing merging of classes you gave
headteachers warning yesterday pupils
are returning tomorrow what does that
mean for children and teenagers now
facing gcse and a-level exams this year
perhaps without their usual teachers
having to merge with other year groups
uh what would you say to those children
our contingency plans being made
for gcse's a levels not to go ahead once
again this year well first of all uh
exams are going ahead uh this year this
summer there's also some examples by the
way they said last year and they didn't
as i said i think there's a big
difference from last year to this year
last
winter january i was the vaccines
minister and we had no vaccines pretty
much or no one vaccinated we only had
very few people vaccinated on the
beginning of the 8th of december of the
year before and only on the 4th of
january of last year did we begin to
scale up the vaccination program with
the astrazeneca vaccine so very big
difference we now have you know 34
million boosters on top of the honey you
know 100 plus million of uh people
of people have had both doses you know
50 million of each dose um so we're in a
very different place in terms of the
vaccination
program we have also i think been
working really positively with the front
line with teachers head teachers to make
sure that they have the test kits in
place
the exams will go ahead the uh merging
of classes is really a mitigation
against staff shortages but i think the
first thing to do is to make sure that
we work with the supply uh uh uh uh
companies of uh temporary staffing which
i've been doing obviously with the call
to get people to come to help out if
they are retired teachers how much
uptake has there been
so by the end of this week i'll be able
to to have that data because obviously
the supply
temperature supply companies will be
able to uh then give us much clearer
data on that we were running at about
eight percent staff absences um at the
end of last year um and of course we are
looking at um
different levels of staff absenteeism
and what those mitigations mean
including as you say if they need to
merge classes the most important thing
for me is to make sure children are in
school
with their teachers in the class
learning and of course we'll go we'll do
everything in our power to make sure
that happens and just on that issue of
absenteeism mr zahawi with the
government preparing for potentially 25
of the workforce uh being off this month
have you also discussed the issue of
potential school closures with head
teachers
well as i say the priorities to keep
schools open
99.9 of schools were open um at the end
of uh last year and i hope we can
continue to make sure that that happens
the testing the staffing
support we're putting in place
and of course the ventilation is going
to make a big difference to uh schools
this year
the most important thing is to keep them
open we obviously plan for all sorts of
measures um we monitor staff absenteeism
i just said to you we're running at
about eight percent last year if that uh
rises further then we look at things
like merging classes teaching uh in
bigger numbers another quick question if
i may miss the hallway we don't have
long left my apologies israel has
started administering a fourth vaccine a
fourth jab is this something that we
could see happening here in the uk
before long
well we have fantastic um uh capability
in terms of looking at the clinical data
in terms of waning of antibodies or t
cells um and i'm sure the team whether
it's chris whitley or jonathan van tam
uh and sarah javid will be looking at
that and whether we need to go for a
fourth jab at the moment the focus is on
the booster uh campaign rightly so
because we know that uh boosting is the
best way to protect yourself your
community uh and of course your family
um so yeah get boosted if you haven't
had that yet but we monitor the the uh
efficacy of the vaccines very closely in
the uk and we're very fortunate to have
you know great scientists who do that
work for us
okay education secretary nadeam's the
hallway thank you very much indeed for
your time today thank you thank you
and we can take a look at the latest
daily cover data released by the
government now 137
580 new cases have been reported in
england and wales
the number of cases has been affected by
a processing issue which inflated the
number of positive tests reported on
previous days
73 deaths were recorded in england and
wales bringing the total number of
deaths within 28 days of a positive test
to 148
851.
the secret settlement between prince
andrew's accuser virginia dufrey and
jeffrey epstein is due to be made public
later today and we can speak to our sky
correspondent ender brady a very good
morning to you and uh what can we expect
well all eyes on a courtroom in new york
later today when this secret document
which was signed and sealed in 2009 will
be made public so it's a document
basically a settlement between the
billionaire pedophile jeffrey epstein
and the woman who accuses prince andrew
of abusing her virginia roberts dufrese
now prince andrew denies all of the
allegations this is a civil action in
the united states his lawyer is a man
called andrew breitler and he has
previously told the new york hearing uh
that this agreement releases prince
andrew and others from any purported
liability arising from the claims miss
duffrey asserted against prince andrew
here it's being heard by a judge lewis
kaplan he's providing over the civil
case he will tomorrow hear a video
telephone conference he will preside
over that tomorrow andrew's team trying
to get the case thrown out as i say he
denies any wrong doing whatsoever we've
no idea if he will be following
proceedings from here but his legal team
will be right across this and of course
speculation over the weekend
that conversations have been had behind
closed doors at the highest level in the
royal household about what to do if
andrew were to lose this civil action in
the united states some speculation that
he could be stripped of his title the
duke of york and calls today from
veterans for him to step back from the
nine military titles he holds in various
different regiments including uh colonel
in chief of the grenadier guards
okay and for now thank you
also making the news this morning an
irish woman injured in an accident in
the united states seven years ago has
died twenty-seven-year-old ifa berry
suffered serious injuries when a balcony
collapsed during her birthday party in
california in 2015 six other people were
killed in the accident
twitter has permanently suspended the
personal account of republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor-green for
repeatedly breaking its covert
misinformation policy ms greene was
flagged after posting false claims about
deaths caused by vaccines she called the
tech company an enemy to america
president biden has told the ukrainian
leader vladimir zelensky that the united
states will respond decisively if russia
invades ukraine
last week vladimir putin warned mr biden
not to impose new sanctions on his
country ukrainian officials say more
than a hundred thousand russian troops
are now positioned on their eastern
border
countries across europe continue to
change their travel restrictions for
visitors from the uk our europe
correspondent adam parsons joins me now
very good morning good morning to you
adam what changes are on the horizon now
yeah it's an interesting one for europe
because there is a patchwork
of restrictions
and this happened last year as well is
that what the european union would like
is to have one unified approach and
they're getting nothing like that yet
some countries
which are pretty lacks in their controls
uh or accommodating you might say others
which are being
very strict i think as a general rule
traveling across europe now if you're
coming from outside the european union
and you want to go to an eu country you
probably will need to have proof of full
vaccination
but then once you get into the doors and
you have to use some past to show that
vaccination well that applies in in many
nations across the east and west now
what's happening today varies from
country to country germany which has a
very strict rule against people coming
in
from the uk
has has backed down on that now so if
you are coming from the uk
to germany you can now get into that
country without facing that the same
lengthy quarantine that you would have
done over the the christmas and new year
period
france though
still has rules that make it very very
hard to get in there if you're coming
from the uk frankly makes it very hard
actually at the moment to transit
through france they've allowed leeway
for uh people who are coming from the uk
and
may live and have residency in another
eu country who need to go through france
to get to that country for a while it
seemed as if the french were stopping
that happening they've now said you can
do that
during uh the christmas new year period
don't know when that's going to to come
to an end but restrictions in france
introduced as of today uh on uh on bars
on the nighttime
economy and also saying that people
really do need to uh to work from home
more we've seen a very very significant
rise in the number of omicron cases in
france over the past week or so and for
an example let's look at greece which
now has said that those sort of high
protection those ffp2 masks are now
mandatory uh in supermarkets and and
other settings there are moves up and
down but the general feeling in the the
eu i think is that things are being
tightened once more
okay adam for now thank you
and israel has announced it will give a
fourth coronavirus vaccine to everyone
aged over 16. health officials there
have warned despite a high uptake of the
jab they are seeing a big increase in
the new number of omicron cases
hello hospices caring for terminally ill
patients say they're facing a cash
crisis because of a lack of fundraising
events the care they provide is funded
by donations and thousands of regular
charity events have been cancelled
because of the pandemic sky's charlotte
low mass reports
this beautiful building is actually a
hospice providing critical care
staff here in romford essex treat
patients with life-limiting conditions
the demand for this has risen
significantly funding however has not
the situation is that we're in financial
challenge because we only get 30 percent
of our funding from the nhs and the rest
we have to fundraise and that has been
exceptionally difficult through covert
times
so one call is help we need more money
and the other is for frontline staff we
need to recruit more to cope with the
increase in pressures that we're under
you want hands and legs
yeah calvin haddow has a chronic
inflammatory lung disease he could
manage his condition at home but
requires regular treatment he's keen to
show how the hospice provides much more
than end-of-life care when i got here so
it was totally different from what i'd
expected
it was a very positive place
i mean i know hospice by very nature of
being a hospice
um
people do die here
but a lot of people don't
and that's the important thing
when you come in here it's not a feeling
of gloom and doom
far from it
i learned to live again to some extent
here you know i really did
the hospice needs to raise eight million
pounds a year to carry on supporting
patients and not just those on the ward
the vast majority
almost 85
live in the community kate marling is
one of a team of nurses who visit them
she worked throughout the pandemic
ensuring patients could stay at home and
be with loved ones
she says people need the hospice more
than ever it's a 24-hour service so as
well as going out and during the day to
support people and their families at
home we also have a 24-hour advice line
that a nurse will always answer um and
the reassurance and comfort that that
gives to people is is huge and we need
to be able to continue to do that
the department of health and social care
has said it's incredibly grateful to
hospices for their ongoing work a cash
boost of 32 million pounds will be
provided over the next four months but
hospices are worried about what happens
when that runs out for now they're
lifting the financial load taking the
pressure off the hospitals but hospices
need continued and guaranteed funding to
carry on
charlotte lomas sky news
also this morning a coach at one of
canada's biggest hockey teams has
thanked a fan who told him to see a
doctor after spotting a mole on the back
of his neck
medical student nadia popovici was
sitting behind the vancouver canucks
dugout when she wrote a message on her
phone and showed it to assistant
equipment manager brian
hamilton hi
hello hi it's so nice to meet you are
you okay with shaking hands
[Music]
the two of them have now been reunited
properly after being removed the mole
was found to be cancerous brian then
tracked down nadia after an appeal on
social media for supporters to help find
her
i really don't
the government says the data on covid
cases doesn't currently point to the
need for fresh restrictions with news
the so-called plan b in england is to be
reviewed on wednesday here's what
education secretary nadim zahawi told me
a little earlier
at the moment there's nothing in the
data
that would suggest uh to me to us that
we need to uh go further but we have to
be uh careful with that because
obviously uh if we see more leakage of
infection in the over 50s
because most of sort of the surge
in infections from omicron has been in
the under 50s
then there is more likely that those
people end up with severe infection and
hospitalization but the good news is
obviously that 90 percent of those
people over 50 have had the booster jab
uh that is the real protection against
severe infection and hospitalization so
uh at the moment there's nothing in the
day to suggest that we need to go
further but of course we will look at
wednesday's review and then beyond that
keep monitoring the data very carefully
and our political correspondent tomorrow
cohen is in westminster for us hello to
you tomorrow so despite it looking
likely before christmas that there could
be more restrictions that may not now be
the case we have seen a bit of a shift
since the run-up to christmas sally and
i think there is great optimism in
government now that more restrictions in
england will not be needed certainly
will not be needed in the in the next
few days what's called plan b the
guidance to work from home and to wear
masks indoors will be reviewed on
wednesday when the cabinet meets and i
get the sense that they'll keep most of
that in place for now but probably won't
add any more restrictions in england
other than what the education secretary
set out in particular for secondary
schools as they reopen this week which
is increased mask wearing at your desk
in the classroom you'll have to wear a
mask and they want every single
secondary school pupil to take a lateral
flow test on site before they return to
school to try and slow the transmission
there but other than that it doesn't
look like there will be restrictions on
social mixing in england announced soon
but nadim zahar we did sound a note of
caution there that while the cabinet
will be very carefully looking at the
hospitalization data in london over the
next couple of days some of that data
has been disrupted over the christmas
period
to see where we are in terms of
hospitalizations one of the key
indicators is how many older people are
now getting omicron having been a surge
of younger people initially because
those people are more likely to get
severe disease so the hospitalization
data but obviously combined with how
many nhs staff are off sick with covid
because although we have fewer people in
hospital than we did this time last year
the huge numbers of infections means
that you've got something like 1 in 10
nhs staff off sick which also adds to
that pressure so they'll weigh it up
very carefully but the feeling in
government is optimism at the moment
that more restrictions won't be needed
okay tomorrow for now thank
you well with the ongoing warnings of
staff shortages and problems in schools
because of omicron the race to vaccinate
as many people as possible against the
virus continues and we can speak now to
dr emil mehta a gp a very warm welcome
to you thank you very much indeed for
joining us this morning now you work in
redbridge if i'm not mistaken a borough
with one of the lowest vaccination rates
in the uk
what are you seeing in terms of the
impact that's having good morning to you
uh so yeah so the last uh several months
has been extremely busy we've seen uh
the initial sort of uh um cohorts being
vaccinated we're now in the booster
campaign in redbridge um and life has
been busy we've been vaccinating in our
practice up to three or four hundred
people every day so um
we i think that's that's our real
challenge in terms of uh what we uh how
we come out of this and and the real
sort of notion of the race against the
vaccine is it couldn't be truer uh i
think this uh this is an absolute
critical time in the pandemic and the
more we vaccinate uh the the better the
the greater chance that we have of
getting out of this pandemic sooner
now we were speaking to the edges
to the health education secretary on the
program uh a little earlier
and he said there is now data to show
that there is an increase in infection
of omicron in the age group but for over
50s it was it was younger people before
how much does this concern you and is
this what you're seeing too
well it is concerning i think the the
concern is that does this new variant
have greater severity of disease than
older older people
and if it does what what impact does
that have on our nhs i think
it's too early to see what's happened in
the last few days in terms of the
numbers that have been admitted to
hospital etc but i think what we're
concentrating on in in primary care in
general practices is to vaccinate as
many people as we can throughout the
next few weeks
and of course an nhs trust in
lincolnshire has now declared a critical
incident because of staffing shortages
there one in 10
members of the nhs workforce off work on
new year's eve are you seeing a pressure
on the nhs in terms of absenteeism and
how concerning is that to you well that
is concerning i think the infectivity of
this virus is clear um not only do we
have a concern about the absences but
we've got an exhausted nhs workforce who
have been out at this process over the
last couple of years i think we've got
to bear in mind that staff are
absolutely exhausted
with increased infection rates i think
we've got to be careful uh and we must
not forget the the sort of routine work
that carries on in general practicing
primary care looking after the
chronically ill people anyway so yes i
am desperately concerned but i think we
are more hopeful than we were in
december 2020 when we started the
vaccination program uh out outright so
yeah
now with schools returning tomorrow more
than a third of 16 and 17 year olds
eligible for the vaccine haven't
taken it how much does that concern you
it is concerning although i must say
that you know the last couple of weeks
we've seen more younger people come up
to the practice to be vaccinated so i
think the next few weeks are really
really critical we've got to encourage
our youngsters to get vaccinated we know
that this is a
easily spread virus it's a respiratory
virus
so let's encourage all your listeners to
to get vaccinated
and the younger cohorts the school going
children are absolutely critical to get
to get done also
but of course uh covert doesn't have a
serious impact on most teenagers and
many may feel they don't need to have
the vaccine they'd rather get immunity
naturally from catching the virus what
would you say to them i think the
concern is really that uh you know you
can be an asymptomatic carrier and if
you are a child going back home to to
older parents etc older grandparents
you may be the cause of passing on
infection to them so
yes
younger children may not be severely
affected but they may carry the virus
onto households
okay dr anil mehta thank you very much
indeed for your time today we wish you
well with your work this winter thank
you
welcome back and with us now to review
the papers this morning our broadcaster
pete price and journalist and author
janelle aldrid hello to you both again
thanks again for joining us
now we're going to kick off with you
janelle first uh the mail you picked out
today the pressure on the prime minister
over soaring energy
bills yeah i think um fuel poverty is
something that we talk about many years
but this year we could see the cap of
the bills rising to around 2 000 pounds
a year now that boris johnson is
undergoing pressure from his back
benches to scrap the green taxes that
add around 200 pounds a year and also to
honor a brexit campaign pledge to scrap
vat which would be another 60 pounds now
although 260 pounds might not sound like
a lot to ministers some of whom are on 3
000 lunches on our dime
it is a lot for families and i think
it's really important that um we take a
look at the most vulnerable amongst us
because they'll be the ones most hit the
elderly and then children and this leads
back into the conversation around things
like lock down furlough if we do this
how about affect people's money people's
bills because we don't want anyone to go
cold i think in a country of our size
and our economics it is a shame if
people have to go without fuel just to
save um some money
yeah pete what's your views on that uh
what are you hearing up in liverpool
from people about the cost of soaring
energy prices they have just risen
astronomically this year last year
people are very frightened very
frightened and
it really is a scary time um to keep
warm and so many people will leave the
heating off will not use the gas will
not use electricity because they're
frightened and they'll be frightened by
this story as well and they'll start
thinking what are we doing what can we
save money on uh the government have got
to step in on this we we hear about all
these subsidies um
towards new fuel ideas
they've got to give something back we've
just been through a pandemic as well so
we don't and we still are in it we still
we need people to be warm in their homes
because that's all we've got
so many people still are frightened to
go out especially the elderly
and pete that perhaps plays into this
story as well that you've picked out in
the eye today that the pandemic has
created a tsunami of anxiety
it's being described as but of course
the cost of living is i'm sure not
helping with that
this story is really really depressing
it's saying that 700
doctors and frontline staff are
asking for help crying out for help uh
with their mental well-being um and
we've got to remember also the ambulance
at fire brigade
police
who also had to deal with this and had
to go and help people because of the
lockdown and what upsets me most is that
mental health um the situation in this
country is is not brilliant anyway the
help for it there's people on waiting
lists waiting to see people for
months and months and months so if these
poor doctors and frontline staff are
suffering i mean i i couldn't work in a
hospital anyway i don't know where they
get their amazing ability from uh
because they're
i mean
a e just up the road from where i live
now is busy very very busy a friend of
mine's just been taken into hospital not
with covert but they're there for like
hours on end and the staff are just
exemplary exemplary just so good but i
don't know how they deal with their
health a prison and i don't know what's
gonna happen and it is a tsunami
and janelle just just your views on that
as well this article really is quite
shocking in the way it describes what
nhs frontline staff are going through
and of course we're seeing the high
numbers of
absenteeism at the moment in the nhs as
well and this i'm sure is not helping
no it's not and and you can see it or
you know i can see as i you know i have
a day job and go back to work and talk
to people just the levels of anxiety
people have about re-entering life
re-entering society you know even me you
know i had a panic attack um driving my
car on the motorway after lockdown ended
and never before have i had any issues
driving my car so the people at the
front line seeing all of this we we
can't think that they are somehow not
affected by seeing how affected all the
patients they deal with are and i think
we also really need to consider not only
just absenteeism over covid but over
their mental health and how we look
after them so that we we don't continue
to burn them out in such big numbers and
and just leading on from that article in
the eye describing a mental health
crisis among frontline doctors and
nurses you've picked out
uh another article which describes
vulnerable children waiting years for
mental health services
yeah and if we think you know adults
aren't coping well with a pandemic what
about children with their you know yet
um fully formed minds in that sense so
in south yorkshire in one case um a
child waited three years for some mental
health support and in staffordshire
seven days and in bromley in south east
london it's on average around three
months now the lenti the lengthy weight
to see and seek help means that more
children end up actually in crisis
because by the time they see someone
those issues worsen and worsen and
there's a story about a young girl whose
mom had moved away and she's studying
for her a levels very much isolated and
alone now the nhs have proposed seeing
people within 28 days of um a referral
but clearly that is not happening and
then alongside with that there's the
shortage of beds that means some
children young people are often on adult
wards there is a whole um circular
situation and and disorder in the nhs
and i think the government really need
to get a handle on this and sort this
out certainly in that article it is
being described as a scandal uh pete
just moving on uh to a slightly
different
pandemic related story a dutch riot
police clashing with anti-lockdown
protesters that again being reported in
the independent
indeed
can i just say though to add to what
that lovely lady has just said parents
should do more by taking their children
off computers off phones and get them
talking human beings talking to human
beings face to face that will help an
awful lot with mental health problems
and then going over to holland
wow my favorite people in the world are
the dutch i'm surprised at them writing
um there's another lock down uh we all
want to
get back to normal but i don't think
rioting is helping and the cost
of of managing this riot uh and we've
seen the pictures a lot of people very
angry these probably are the people that
are anti-vaxxers as well so they're not
helping anybody at all by being
anti-vaxxers but i love the dutch and
i'm surprised at this and it's very sad
and it looked quite brutal hundreds of
people on the streets saying we're not
going into a lockdown again we don't
like it we don't want it briefly from
you janelle on that it's not just
anti-vaxxers who are protesting do you
think that perhaps there is just less
goodwill this time in terms of changing
your life and knocking down and being
willing to accept restrictions
people don't generally i think want to
be stuck in their homes and i think also
i mean can't say about there but in this
country definitely the government have
had their part to play in people not
wanting to be locked down again because
people feel it's one rule for us and one
rule for them i think so much has
happened in these 18 months with
families not being able to be together
in some of the
best and worst moments of life people
passing lack of being able to mourn that
and be together in those times and then
we see you know i hate to bring it up
the cheese and winegate and all these
other stories that come out it makes
people reluctant to follow the rules and
i'm not saying that it's right but i'm
saying that the way human behavior is
the way people are is that we tend to
not want to do things if the people
telling us to do it are not doing it
themselves and i think that has played a
lot into the public psyche around
lockdowns and so i think our government
have to take their share from them i'm
so sorry i'm going to have to interrupt
you because i really want to get to this
story before i let you go of the uh
hockey player who was saved by a fan
when she spotted his mole please quickly
tell us about that
22 year old ice hockey fan saw one of
the coaches of a hockey team he had a
mole on his neck it looked cancerous to
her she'd volunteered in cancer wards
she wrote him a note on her phone stuck
it up against the glass he said that
when he saw it he was mid-game so he
kind of shrugged it off but did go and
get it checked out three days later he's
told that left years it could have been
life-threatening they tracked her down
on twitter and then they also gave her
ten thousand dollars which she's going
to use to help her get to medical school
and she is being described as a hero as
are you both pete price and janelle we
will see you in next hour thank you very
much indeed